[Musique]
pour la première fois depuis plus de dix
jours missiles et roquettes cessent leur
envolée vers les camps adverses
une trêve particulièrement espéré par la
communauté internationale l'a vu des
innombrables bombardements mutuelle
entre les deux belligérants
c'est désormais officiel après
d'intenses tractations diplomatiques en
coulisses israël et le mouvement
palestinien hamas se sont entendus hier
soir sur un cessez le feu sous médiation
égyptienne
entrée en vigueur dans la nuit le
cabinet de sécurité a accepté ce soir à
l'unanimité la recommandation de tous
les responsables de la sécurité du chef
d'état major de l'armée de défense
d'israël du chef de liesse à du chef du
mossad et du chef du conseil de sécurité
nationale d'accepter l'initiative
égyptienne d'un cessez le feu mutuelle
sans conditions préalables
nous avons été informés par les frères
égyptiens qu'un accord avait été conclu
pour un cessez-le feu bilatéral
simultanée dans la bande de gaza à
partir de 2 heures du matin la
résistance palestinienne respectera cet
accord aussi longtemps que l'occupation
le respectera l'egypte qui entretient à
la fois des relations avec le hamas et
tel aviv a joué un rôle majeur dans
l'aboutissement de ces négociations
permettez moi de partager avec vous le
fait que les efforts déployés par
l'égypte et les autres parties ont porté
leurs fruits avec un cessez le feu très
prochainement éloigna nous espérons
qu'il durera tout l'été mois qui vont
sauver mary d'être sauvés grâce à tous
les efforts que nous déployons cool la
gare des mômes kim pour le président
américain joe biden
ce cessez le feu représente une réelle
opportunité de paix au proche orient
je suis convaincu que les palestiniens
et les israéliens méritent autant de
vivre en sécurité et de jouir demain
niveau de liberté de prospérité et de
démocratie
mon administration poursuivra notre
diplomatie discrète et infatigable pour
aller vers cet objectif
je suis convaincu que nous avons une
vraie opportunité d'avancer et je
m'engage à travailler en cette direction
et qu'elles font
dans les rues de gaza le soulagement et
les scènes de liesse prédomine après
presque deux semaines d'une vie
extrêmement éprouvante
reste désormais à voir si cet accord
sera respectée sur la durée un point sur
lequel a déjà insisté l'onu appelant les
parties concernées à faire preuve de
responsabilité